tous ces arbres qui surplombe la
promenade du rail à la chine n'existait
pas il ya sept ans on voit encore les
mêmes les mêmes gros caillou mais autour
il y avait bien la bande de terrains
autrefois en plein soleil procure
maintenant un peu d'ombré aux résidents
du secteur
l'organisme dirigé par jonathan théorêt
ya planté plus de 200 arbres dans 50 ans
on peut estimer que les les abords ça va
générer un corridor qui est
particulièrement plus frais puis déjà
aujourd'hui on en ressent les bénéfices
pour combattre la chaleur
chaque arbre fait une différence dans
des parcs industriels et du
stationnement il y as souvent de
l'espace pour en planter mais c'est loin
d'être réflexes dans cet hôtel près de
l'aéroport de montréal on a décidé d'en
ajouter 146 si on regarde alentours de
notre fait pratiquement ignore pas grand
chose des arbres et des affaires comme
ça c'est que nous on va faire notre
portion puis j'espère que les autres
vont faire la même chose
le meilleur temps pour planter un arbre
c'est toujours maintenant aujourd'hui
urgence climatique il faut pas attendre
d'être au pied du mur avant de planter
il faut planter aujourd'hui entre les
briques l'asphalté et le béton du mile
end
il peut faire jusqu'à 10 degrés de plus
que sur le parc du mont royal situé tout
juste à côté
la présence de plus de végétation dans
un quartier peut réduire la température
dans le quartier et ça peut aller de 1 2
3 degrés ça peut paraître petit mais
croyez moi une journée chaude ça fait
une séance
la ville de montréal est en voie de
remplir son objectif de planter 100
mille arbres en disant on est dans la
petite pointe de monstres que vous voyez
ici donc dans un îlot de chaleur coin
hochelaga et honoré-beaugrand la ville a
retiré une bande d'asphalté dans ce
stationnement pour y planter quelques
arbres et apporter un peu de fraîcheur
leezam ont vraiment eu un impact très
important de vous local si on se déplace
si on veut à dix mètres plus loin on le
sent moins mais quand on est vraiment à
proximité des arbres c'est un impact
direct
l'an dernier une centaine d'aménagement
comme celui ci ont été ajoutés un peu
partout en ville
cette année ce sera plus de 300 le
combat se mène un arbre à la fois
ici olivier vachon radio canada montréal